[Música]
bienvenidos a los más vulnerables un
programa sobre cómo esta pandemia afecta
a los cientos de millones de personas
que ya vivían en situaciones de pobreza
de hacinamiento de marginalidad o se
veían obligadas a migrar o estaban en
guerras y conflictos mi nombre andrés
suárez jaramillo
hoy vamos a abordar el tema del regreso
a clases en varias partes del mundo
luego de haber llegado el momento de
iniciar un nuevo año académico esto
supone grandes retos en la forma de cómo
llevar la educación a los niños más
vulnerables en tiempos de pandemia
comenzamos entonces en el salvador donde
se prevé que los colegios reabrirán
hasta el 2021 en su lugar se implementó
la enseñanza virtual pero esto dejó en
evidencia la brecha digital entre los
habitantes de las ciudades y los del
campo nuestro corresponsal en el
salvador- vladimir chamorro nos trae la
historia
y luís que cursan séptimo grado nunca
imaginaron que su salón de clases se
reduciría al whatsapp en su teléfono
celular y sus sillas estarían en la copa
de un árbol
y aquí yo está más porque no es como
estar sentado uno en la casa teniendo
buena señal o wifi
sentado uno no corre ningún peligro y
puede estar haciendo las tareas
a veces nos reunimos y vamos a lugares
más lejos a buscar señal y con más
altura pues así decir vamos a enseñar
aunque a veces sí
en santa rosa cerca una aldea
salvadoreña de poco más de 1000
habitantes cerca de guatemala la
cobertura de internet es poca o nula
caminar 20 minutos para encontrar una
buena señal se ha vuelto algo habitual
para los universitarios de la comunidad
nosotros tenemos el interés de
superarnos porque a comparación de otros
que tal vez si tienen las facultades en
como que no hacen el trabajo como se
debe a cambio nosotros que nos cuesta un
poco más siempre tratamos la manera de
que estar a tiempo con las tareas y
mientras el cierre de los centros
educativos se extenderá hasta el 2021
estos estudiantes deberán seguir
gastando hasta cuatro dólares para
recargar internet en sus móviles un
costo elevado para hogares con ingresos
de 250 dólares al mes
1 porque como en realidad poco estudio
tiene va es poco lo que les puede ayudar
pero si se les ayuda cuando se puede y
de igual manera va tienen que estar
ellos poniendo internet y a veces pueden
a veces no pueden y así va se les ha
dificultado bastante
según la fundación salvadoreña para el
desarrollo económico y social sólo el 61
por ciento de los estudiantes mayores de
10 años usa internet la mayoría en el
área además de revelar la brecha digital
entre la ciudad decía el campo la
pandemia mostró que el país tiene aún
mucho trecho que andar en cuanto a la
digitalización del estado
méxico y cuba son dos países en donde
también están clausurados los colegios y
las escuelas pero sus gobiernos han
puesto en práctica las clases escolares
a través de la televisión las teleclases
serán el recurso para el aprendizaje de
distancia hasta tanto no haya una
disminución en los contagios de
coronavirus aquí la historia
criticada por su exclusivo rol de
entretenimiento la televisión está
cambiando de piel en méjico niños de
escasos recursos que carecen de señal de
internet en sus hogares rurales han
podido estudiar diariamente gracias a un
programa de aprendizaje en casa
transmitido en grandes cadenas como tv
azteca
esta estrategia educativa nos permite
ingerir y por supuesto que va a tener
muchas limitaciones sin nada como el
trato directo entre alumno alumno alumno
maestro etcétera entonces creo que no
necesariamente va a implicar una baja en
su rendimiento académico ni en su
educación alrededor de un 94 por ciento
de los mexicanos cuentan con un
televisor en sus hogares según cifras
oficiales esto así es muy diferente en
esta ocasión porque no hay esa
retroalimentación siempre las
ocurrencias que ellos tienen las
contestaciones la alegría que te da
saber que lograron ellos construir el
concepto en esta ocasión pues no no la
tengo los en la vecina cuba donde una
señal de internet es un lujo costoso los
estudiantes en la habana también reciben
clases portales
en este caso a través de un canal
estatal cuando comenzó todo se sentí
algo de miedo porque jamás había faltado
a la escuela y pensé que iba a extrañar
a los maestros que de hecho así fue pero
en realidad me ha servido para
interactuar conmigo misma para hacerme
más independiente con mis estudios a
goody más a los libros en el caso de
estas hermanas que viven en la periferia
de la capital cubana se educan con
programas de televisión que tardan una
hora en materias como matemáticas
lenguaje historia y geografía como ellas
miles de estudiantes ansían que este
método les valga para presentar sus
exámenes y ascender de curso en lugar de
retrasar todo para el 2021 tanto jugó
como méxico han mantenido la política de
mantener las escuelas cerradas hasta
tanto no haya un marcado descenso en los
contagios por kobe 19 vamos a un destino
en donde las condiciones socioeconómicas
han llevado a que las clases no sean por
televisión sino por radio esto
ocurre en sudan del sur un país donde el
cierre escuelas y colegios ya cuenta
cuatro meses a las comunidades rurales
de esta nación africana llegaron 500
radios destinados al aprendizaje a
distancia como una alternativa educativa
en un país que apenas invierte el 5.6
por ciento de su presupuesto nacional en
educación
y los radios son alimentados con energía
solar 500 de ellos llegaron a las
comunidades de yambio en el suroeste
sudan del sur en esta soleada mañana
varios maestros imparten clases de
inglés así como ofrecen recomendaciones
en los cuidados a tener durante la
pandemia
corona debido al korona vides todas las
escuelas están cerradas nuestros hijos
no tienen forma de ir a sus clases estas
radios les ayudarán durante este tiempo
en que las escuelas están cerradas
estamos muy contentos y agradecemos a la
onu en sudán del sur por proporcionar
estas radios para ayudar a nuestros
hijos
[Música]
las clases por radio se dan de lunes a
viernes una hora en la mañana y una hora
en la tarde la iniciativa ha traído gran
alegría en esta comunidad africana luego
de cuatro meses de confinamiento y de
más de cinco años de una dolorosa guerra
civil
necesitamos que el gobierno y sus socios
nos ayuden a bancas de kings nuestras
niñas se están quedando embarazadas
porque las escuelas están cerradas hemos
pasado cuatro meses sin educación y
quedándonos en casa
esta iniciativa de aprendizaje a través
de la radio es un proyecto de unicef la
organización de la onu para la infancia
quien recientemente denunció que sudan
del sur es el país que menos invierte
dinero en educación de la región
mientras el promedio de inversión es del
20 por ciento del presupuesto nacional
este país solo pone el 5,6 por ciento lo
que deja cerca de 22 millones de niños
sin acceso a educación de calidad y en
un grave peligro hacia el futuro
vamos a europa donde varios países
dieron inicio al regreso de los niños a
las clases presenciales en colegios y
escuelas en francia para el gobierno de
manuel macrón resultaba fundamental que
la reapertura de los colegios comenzará
el 2 de septiembre nuestra periodista en
parís el ica olavarría nos entrega los
detalles el confinamiento aumentó las
desigualdades y también las dificultades
de un grupo de alumnos en un contexto en
que 1 de cada 5 niños vive en francia
bajo el umbral de la pobreza según el
ministro educación jean-michel blanquea
500000 de casi 12 millones de alumnos
perdieron todo contacto con la escuela
durante el confinamiento y eso es
primero por falta de la tecnología para
hacerlas a distancia pero también por
falta de apoyo y seguimiento de los
padres la escuela también es fundamental
pues muchos niños vulnerables comen allí
es el lugar donde adquieren la
alimentación diaria y para algunos niños
que sufren violencia doméstica es un
refugio por lo mismo las medidas que
tomó el gobierno de manuel macrón para
el regreso a clases fue aumentar en 100
euros el bono que da a las familias para
la compra de materiales pues éstos
además aumentaron de pres
también creó 1.700 puestos de profesores
para apoyar en el refuerzo de aquellos
niños que llegan con más deficiencias
debido a esta distancia que se creó con
la escuela además se decidió dar
gratuitamente a 3 millones de hogares
más vulnerables las mascarillas que
recordemos son obligatorias a partir de
los 11 años y también se dice que está
todo listo en caso de que hubiera un
nuevo confinamiento que hay tabletas
para que los niños puedan llevársela a
sus hogares la situación es semejante en
el resto de europa concretamente en
italia se criticó mucho al gobierno
porque los alumnos no volvieron a clase
tras el levantamiento del confinamiento
y sólo lo han hecho ahora en este
regreso de un nuevo año escolar pasemos
ahora a revisar un caso de medio oriente
en irán los colegios y las escuelas
reabrieron sus puertas para recibir a
cerca de 15 millones de estudiantes esto
ocurrió desde el 5 de septiembre en
medio de fuertes críticas de
profesionales de la salud expresando su
preocupación por la reapertura en uno de
los países más golpeados por la pandemia
el coronavirus en
acostumbrados a un confinamiento de
siete meses millones de niños regresaron
a las aulas en irán pero lo hicieron
atendiendo todas las medidas que hacen
parte de la nueva normalidad toma de
temperatura lavado de manos desinfección
de zapatos y uso de mascarilla y careta
de protección
inspeccionamos a los estudiantes al
ingresar a las instalaciones de la
escuela atendemos los protocolos de
salud dándoles caretas faciales y
desinfectantes observamos el
distanciamiento social y colocamos a los
estudiantes en burbujas especiales para
ayudar a prevenir la propagación de
coronavirus entre ellos y mantenerlos
saludables muchos padres de este colegio
en teherán recibieron con agrado la
reapertura escolar la decisión fue
tomada por el presidente hassan roan y
quien puso a la educación en el mismo
estadio de importancia que a la salud
oms estábamos preocupados debido a la
reapertura de las escuelas hice todo lo
posible para enseñarle a mi hijo cómo
debe observar los protocolos de salud
mental y en mi opinión en casa no puedo
enseñarle a mi usando los mismos métodos
que usan en la escuela prefiero que
asistan físicamente a clases
pero con cerca de 400.000 casos de
contagio y más de 22 mil muertes por
kobe 19 irán es el país más afectado por
la pandemia en el medio oriente por lo
que muchos critican esta reapertura
escolar no sé por qué las escuelas
reabrieron con este método de protección
bien fuera para convencer a los padres o
por otro motivo en otros países
reabrieron escuelas con protocolos de
salud similares también pero no sé la
razón por la que las escuelas han
reabierto así en irán
durante los siete meses de confinamiento
en irán el aprendizaje a distancia junto
a las aplicaciones de internet y a los
programas de televisión pero ahora con
la reapertura de colegios los padres
tienen en su propio albedrío decidir si
es tiempo de enviar a sus hijos de
vuelta a las clases presenciales
y así terminamos este programa dedicado
a informar sobre el regreso a las clases
de los niños y niñas más vulnerables
ustedes muchas gracias y recuerden que
más información la pueden encontrar en
nuestro sitio web france24 puntocom
[Música]